trained in like wrestling like before he
did YouTube yep uh what like sparked
your interest in wrestling from the
beginning was it something you were just
always into so I don't remember a point
in my life when I wasn't into wrestling
and like when I was little I loved like
Bret Hart and Hulk Hogan Hulk Hogan much
less eventually for many reasons
more more than a few that guy sucks in
about 12 different ways but um so then
anyway I um I actually worked this job
that I really really liked and I got
fired and it was like devastating it was
like just this was pre YouTube and it
[__] sucked and I was like okay
I thought I was like kind of following
all the right paths and doing all the
right things like professionally and now
I kind of have nothing and especially
like I knew my confidence was super low
and I was like okay [__] it Pie in the
Sky what do you want to pursue like what
do you want to go after and I was like
maybe it could be a wrestler I'm trying
so I looked it up and there was actually
this wrestling school within like three
miles of my place and then so I just
started training there for like six
months and the only reason I stopped is
like a
that [__] is so hard and I say that as
someone who has done like contact
martial arts pretty much my whole life
professional wrestling was like the
toughest training I've ever done damn it
because like with martial arts the
object is to you know the objective is
to not get your head kicked in yeah this
was like no you're gonna get [__]
destroyed yeah
um and so I did that and the only reason
I stopped is because like YouTube
started to kind of become a thing and I
was like I gotta put my whole ass into
one of these things you know yeah so
like that's that's a badass origin story
imagine imagine training to be a
wrestler and then yeah I'm gonna make
anime videos
I mean compared to anyone else I know in
the anime Community
throw in some dude around the ring
thinking of being pissed off for Hunter
Hunter
would you do any like you know YouTuber
like kind of like sporting or boxing
events uh like becoming a thing now
would you ever consider doing that
especially with your totally kind of
like you know I would be very afraid of
your opponent I feel like you were you
have the drive that is terrifying
if you could make a video like that
about Garfield what could you do if you
actually had to fight what did I do to
the human body I just I just don't want
to know
do you have like a dream entrance you
would make if you like ever did like a
sporting event like that because you
know you you love you love your
wrestling I know I think the problem is
I've had a couple over the years I think
you know what
uh rather than going for like a big
heavy theme song I think it'd be kind of
badass to walk into Good's theme
[Music]
like real undertaker
helped me so badass
yeah because like you obviously made a
video you know about berserk as well
would you say like do you have like I
know this is
I [__] question every anime YouTuber
hates but you're on a podcast I got to
ask you do you have like a top five or
like things that like anime that mean
the most to you oh so I think berserk is
like the best story ever yeah
and I read books
I think I think berserk is legit like
the best thing we as a species have done
um I [__] love it so much and but in
terms of like say anime I I could
probably do a top five I think my top
three are like Evangelion Hunter Hunter
you you hack show Cowboy Bebop number
four and I could probably pick something
number five but yeah that'd be kind of
the rough one for me hell yeah
yeah very very respectable list
I forgot what I was gonna say yeah I
said I I gotta ask how the [__] did you
go into Garfield what was all that about
how did that happen
um I don't know because as I explained
in that video I never had any in okay no
actually it was when I think I was like
someone was telling me that there was a
lot of weird Garfield [__] online and
like I love fandom I love people taking
this license and doing cool [__] with it
yeah like I'm just fascinated by that
process I love fanner I like love
anything that's kind of transformative
like that and someone sent me um or
slash I'm sorry John and I was like oh
weird and I was like I should I should I
my thought at the time was like I should
do like a little 20 minute video about
this what is uh what is it I'm sorry
John is like a subreddit of the most
[__] up fan art you can imagine
oh God what is that yeah so yeah it's
it's that
um there's another one called or slash
I'm really sorry John oh my God I really
don't advise people look at that oh god
um and so but like I just became
fascinated with like how did we get to
this point yeah and then like um I
remember I was kind of my mom was asking
me what I'm working on so I'm playing
around with this idea of um of Garfield
and like you know this it this weird
fandom around it and she was like um
someone who spends a little time on
there rightfully so but
um I said to my mom and she was like oh
yeah because you used to have your your
little Garfield Teddy and I was like no
wait what no I didn't oh no and then and
then she was like Hey dude and I was
like I think you're thinking of like my
cousin and then she was like no no you
did and then I was like I [__] didn't
and then she sends me a photo of as a
kid holding this scarf and I'm like what
the [__] at that point it kind of
triggered the idea that like Garfield is
this kind of an Eldritch being really
and I it was just it just became such a
fun narrative to make you know hell yeah
yeah because do you have like a process
in terms of like how you come up with
video ideas because you know it started
off with anime and now it's just like
[__] anything you know like is it
just kind of like when you where you can
find like an interesting story or is
there something that draws you it's just
I get an idea in my head and I kind get
rid of it and I think at the point one
of my friends are like would you [__]
stop talking about this that's when it's
like I should probably make a video
about it
that's actually kind of sick though
that's kind of yeah oh a lot of it's
really sick like a lot of it's so so
cool because you didn't want a
girlfriend you did one on Sonic as well
if I remember correctly oh yeah yeah
that was a fun one yeah remember the day
I remember
um I was like looking up all parts of
Sonic and there's basically a day I
basically had to go on PornHub and be
like let's see what's on PornHub how
much Sonic porn there is on PornHub
right and then we don't need to search
it out I'm like I'm like looking I'm
like looking at all this stuff and I get
a phone call from my dad yeah and like
my dad will usually call me when I get
something kind of serious like he's the
one who'll be like okay this is like
John listen
this is global pandemic starting and uh
I think we're all probably gonna have to
stay inside for a little while and just
so you know don't go outside and it was
a really harrowing phone call right and
then like I'm like okay cheers dad I
appreciate it and I turn it I hang up
the phone and I turn back to my monitor
and there's a Rouge the Bat sucking
Shadow the Hedgehog sticks
[Laughter]
about how weird my job is I've never had
that moment where I'm just searched I
mean you you uh do some weird fandoms
one video I found super fascinating is
when you go into like real life kind of
like the you know kind of like the fake
martial arts that was like one of my
favorite ones as well just because I was
I always grew up watching like a lot of
martial arts films and stuff like that
and just seeing how many like how deep
this Rabbit Hole went it's so weirdly
prolific yeah and the weird thing is
like you would think so for people who
don't know it's like basically these
people who think they have magical
powers they got through martial arts and
they do like the no contact chaos and
all this kind of stuff
um but the weird thing it's still
popular like there's people who still
really believe that stuff